5 musique et france 2 a fait son choix
la chanson de l'été pour notre chaîne
notre coup de coeur ce sera amadou et
mariam ce couple de chanteurs aveugles
venus du mali vous les connaissez sans
doute déjà c'est un gros succès de cette
année 2005 marie hélène bono daniel lévy
amadou et mariam depuis 20 ans ils
promènent ensemble leur musique au mali
puis en france leur album produit par
manu chao leur a valu une victoire de la
musique
et depuis c'est l'explosion
du blues rock africains pour raconter
leur pays et leurs coutumes ils se sont
rencontrés à l'institut pour non voyants
ils sont d histoire haute en couleurs
portées par les notes quand on est
aveugle la musique ça ça joue un très
grand rôle
donc les choses qui se passent autour de
mousson des choses qui nous inspire
c'est comme dit aussi ça nous inspire
beaucoup
donc on fait beaucoup attention et puis
on ferme sur scène manu chao en passager
clandestin
un concert pour chanter la solidarité
c'est tous les messages d'un tas de
messages d'amour mais ç'a eu des
justices message de paix on en a besoin
en ce moment
oui je pense que dans la buzzer parce
que le monde
il faut parler un peu et il faut
toujours parler il faut toujours dire
c'est qu'il ya lieu de faire et c'est
qu'il faut pas faire aussi c'est très
important
plus de cent mille albums vendus une
tournée en france et à l'étranger
jusqu'à l'automne
ce couple continue d'enchanter la france
avec des chansons d'amour tout fabre
enfin